but first let's go to Redding where
we're joined now by the Business
Secretariat Alok Sharma thank you very
much for being on the show today
mr. Sharma now the UK has reported the
highest daily death toll of any European
country 980 people on Friday yesterday
the figure was 917 this is just the
people dying in hospital as well why
people dying at a faster rate in the UK
than in any other country in Europe well
Sophie right from the start of this
whole situation we've always been very
clear that we will follow the scientific
and metal advice that is put to us by
our advisors and we have taken the right
steps at the right time in moving
forward and we've also put forward a
very clear plan in terms of how we
address issues in relation to testing in
relation to getting more PPE into the
into the system and we will continue to
work night and day to make sure that
happens
from my perspective as business sexually
of course we're also doing everything we
can to support businesses to support
jobs to make sure we support people's
livelihoods and that's actually writing
proper and if you look at the full range
of what we put in place with businesses
it is pretty unprecedented even by
international set standards I'm keen to
talk about some of that support for
business later in the interview but I
just want to pick up on you saying that
we took the right steps at the right
time because some people will be looking
at those death numbers and wondering if
that's true on the 3rd of March the
Prime Minister visited a hospital
treating coronavirus patients where he
said that he'd shook hands with people
on the 13th of March tens of thousands
of people went to the Cheltenham
horse-racing festival now by this time
the daily death toll in Italy was 200 we
could see what was happening we could
see it was rising so why didn't we take
action sooner well as I said look we
have followed Sophie the the scientific
and medical advice and will continue to
do that there is a a debate at the
moment I know that's taking place around
when the current measures that we put in
place for people to stay at home will
come to an end and we've been very clear
on this is that you know we are led by
the scientific advice the scientific
flights a group which advises the
government is meeting next week
and they will look at the evidence
that's in place and of course we need to
wait until we are past the peak and as
the chief medical officer has said we
don't know when that will be so we're
going to be led all the way throughout
this process by the medical advice the
health advice that we're getting I think
that's right inappropriate and I think
your viewers watching this will agree
with that you say you've always been led
by the scientific advice but did the
scientific advice get it wrong at the
beginning because on the 13th of March
the day that 70,000 people went to the
Cheltenham Festival
so Patrick Valens the government's chief
scientific adviser said in an interview
our aim is to try and reduce the pink
not suppress it completely because the
vast majority of people get a mild
illness to build up some kind of herd
immunity so will you admit that the
original strategy changed and as a
result lives may have been lost well
look I am extremely sorry for the the
loss of any life that's taken place
through this global pandemic and of
course that that's right and my thoughts
are very much with the families and
loved ones of all those who've lost
their lives the key thing now is to make
sure that people follow the guidance
they stay at home we protect the NHS and
ultimately this is about saving lives so
we are following the scientific and
health advice that we're getting that
advice change well you know as the
situation has evolved obviously we have
looked to see what the advice is and we
have acted on it that advice change so
if it I am NOT a a medical or scientific
expert in these areas and that is why we
have advisors to give us that advice
that is why we have sage and that is why
we follow what it is that they are
telling us to do I accept that you say
that you're following the advice from
the experts but did that advice change
well clearly what we have seen is that
in the in the in the past few weeks we
have asked people to observe the
guidelines to stay at home except for a
number of exceptions and that is about
saving lives and it's also about making
sure that we flatten the peak you know
we can have a discussion around
you know the the timeline on all of this
but I think the reality right now what
people want to see is that the
government is acting on the medical
advice we want to make sure whether
people are following the guidelines that
they're staying at home except for those
exceptions and this is ultimately about
protecting life that is what the
government is trying to do at the same
time as I mentioned at the start of this
discussion we're putting in place a hat
put in place an unprecedented economic
package to support our businesses and
support jobs and livelihoods in our
country so that when we come out the
other side which we will businesses are
ready to bounce back I'm just trying to
work out that if we took the right steps
at the right time why are we posting a
higher daily death toll than any other
European country well different
countries are at different cycles in
terms of where they are in terms of the
spread of this this this pandemic and
what is appropriate right now is that
people follow the advice and the
guidelines that have been set out and I
think particularly we've got another two
days to run of this bank holiday weekend
that you know the weather is very nice
but actually we need to make sure that
people observe the guidelines now I'm
very pleased to say the vast majority of
the public is indeed doing that and they
are staying at home except for there's a
few exceptions that we've set out okay
and I'm keen to ask you about protective
equipment for the NHS because today the
Royal College of Nursing has issued
guidance to say that nurses are within
their rights to refuse to treat patients
with coronavirus if they're not given
adequate personal protective equipment
is that right well it's it's actually
right that no medical professional
should be placed in a position where
they have to make that choice and you
know that is there for me that sort of
sapphic evident that is why we are
making sure that we get protective
equipment to the frontline and you know
you would have seen the plan that's been
put out in terms of making sure that
there is very clear guidance into what
sort of protective equipment people need
in particular settings we've made sure
that there is a huge distribution
network that's now been set up so over
700 million pieces of protective
equipment have been distributed over the
last few weeks and we've also made sure
that we are sourcing
supply's was as well as manufacturing
supply in the UK but we need to put this
in in the context of where we are you
know in a normal circumstance Sophie you
will have us providing PPE to about two
hundred and thirty three hospital trusts
across the country we're now talking
about supplying fifty eight thousand NHS
and social care settings I mean that is
a huge increase and on top of that of
course there is huge global demand for
PPE and that does put a squeeze and
supply but I'm really pleased about is
that we've got British companies coming
forward changing from what they're
normally doing to manufacturing PPE
you've got burglaries which are making
gallons you've got companies like any
awesome BrewDog which are making
sanitizers hand sanitizers and you're
also seeing people like McLaren and
rolls-royce for making advisors and I
think that people have stepped up to
really support this and this is a a
unified effort in making sure that we
get more PPP out there to the frontline
clearly there is a huge demand on
personal protective equipment in the
middle of a pandemic no one would
dispute that and the question is would
our nurses right refuse to treat
patients if they don't feel they've been
given the right protective equipment to
keep them safe look this shouldn't be
placed in that position and that is that
is of course it is the job of government
to make sure that they are not finding
themselves in that position and that is
why we have a program of making sure
that distribution is taking place across
the country as you will have heard we
are setting up a portal over the next
couple of weeks so healthcare settings
can actually directly input what they
require and we can see in real time what
the demand is and then make sure that we
get the supply out there there's a 24/7
hotline for people in NHS or social care
setting to call so that they can get
access to PPE but of course they should
not be placed in that position and I
completely accept that it is up to the
garden to make sure that we fix this if
you accept that and I wonder if you'll
take this opportunity to apologize for
the shortages that we've seen yesterday
pretty Patel said I'm sorry if people
feel there had been failings I mean it
sounds a bit like the kind of apology
you give if you don't really want to say
sorry so will you say sorry to health
care workers well
in the Stantons program I said I was
sorry for the loss of any life through
this pandemic but you know this is we
are facing and we apologize to health
care workers who feel that they don't
have the right protective equipment to
do their jobs well as I said it is our
job to make sure that we get there have
that health care equipment that PPE out
to them right now
that is what your viewers will be asking
is that you know what is the government
doing does the government have a plan to
get this PPP a PPE out to the front line
and the answer is yes we do have a plan
we are putting that in place we're
making sure that there are hundred
millions of of PPE kit equipment which
is going out the front line and of
course you know we need to be doing even
more and that is why we have this plan
of making sure we have additional supply
but we are sourcing but then also doing
home manufacturing in the UK okay now
you are of course the business secretary
and you were speaking bit earlier in the
interview about some of the support that
the government is offering to the
economy that's clearly very difficult
time and you put in place a scheme to
help small and medium-sized businesses
the coronavirus business interruption
loan scheme so as of today how many
loans have been granted under this
scheme well the latest figures that I
have is around four thousand two hundred
and just over eight hundred and million
pounds has gone out what I would say to
you is that you know this has been set
up at speed and we've made additional
changes over the last few days which
have been announced which means that
actually all small and medium sized
businesses up to turn over 45 million
pounds can now access this scheme I
spent the last couple of days talking
directly to some of the largest lenders
who are part of this scheme and I've
been very clear to say to them that we
need to get money out of the door as
quickly as possible
they understand that and banks know that
on this occasion they have to be part of
solution and they want to be part of
solution
you know you've had the organizations
that I've talked to have had people
working and continue to work over this
bank holiday weekend so they can talk to
their customers they can provide that
support and I hope what you will see in
the coming days is a
increase in money flowing out and you
know it is vital that we do everything
we can to support our businesses and of
course protect jobs and that is why I
sort of mention a couple of the other
schemes as well so if your the job
retention scheme again is to make sure
that people can stay in a company so
that when we actually have an an upturn
when we come out of this at which we
will then we are able to go forward and
businesses and quickly restart and take
advantage of that start so begin the
answer you said around 4200 loans being
granted now there's been reportedly
around 300,000 applications
that's just 1.4 percent being granted I
mean this is really concerning there's
no I mean some of these businesses are
gonna go are they're gonna collapse
aren't they well so the first thing I'd
say to is that we have set this up at
Pace and everyone is literally working
around the clock I can tell you as
someone who's been involved in the
setting of a dispute worried that well
of course I mean it's not just a
question of me being worried I I
completely understand the concerns that
businesses have however there is
additional support the rules are
providing so we have made sure that
there are grants available for small and
medium-sized businesses those in pacific
sectors and twelve point three million
pounds has already gone out to local
authorities which are administering that
particular scheme and of that as of the
fifth of April at one point two million
billion pounds have gone out supporting
almost a hundred thousand businesses and
so we are very keen to make sure this
money flows out as quickly as possible
but I'm sure people also understand that
all of these schemes have been set up at
Pace you know people have literally work
around the clock and continue to work
around the clock and let me give that
assurance to any businesses that are
watching this that has business century
and totally committed to making sure
that money goes out as door as quickly
as possible from our skis but also from
the banks and I will continue to have
those daily conversations we spoken out
about the economic consequences of the
lockdown and of course there are some
really serious consequences of a
lockdown as well there's been reports of
people going hungry not getting the food
that they need and pretty vitally
yesterday spoke about
cause about domestic violence increasing
at an alarming rate people using their
jobs has been damaged to mental health
of course as well does there come a
tipping point when the negative
consequences of the lockdown start to
outweigh its need of course to keep the
virus at bay well so if you can ideas
sort of make this point which is that
all of us in government are completely
united on the fact that we need to
follow the scientific and medical but
medical advice that we have we'll follow
the advice that sage gives us and you
know what we need to do first and
foremost is to make sure that we are
saving lives of people across our
country that is absolutely vital but of
course as you say you know this pandemic
has had a big negative impact on the the
economy not just in the UK but indeed
across the world this is a a global
issue but that is why we have put in
place the unprecedented set of schemes
that we have to support businesses and
to make sure people are not losing their
jobs they can be furloughed and so that
when we come out the other side
businesses are able to restart quickly
the government's could be making a
decision later on this week about
whether or not to extend the lockdown it
looks almost inevitable that it will be
extended there's been speculation in the
newspapers this morning and felt the
last couple of days that it could be
until May when we start seeing those
restrictions being eased is that about
right
well I'm not going to enter into a
discussion you'll forgive me for that
Sophie because I think what's important
here is that we let sage do their work
to look at the evidence and then to come
and tell us and government you know what
direction we should be going with this
could it end then if you're looking at
the direction we should be going could
the lockdown be tightened further well
again I'm not going to sort of speculate
on any of this I don't think that's
actually particularly helpful at this
stage but what is important is the
clarity the message which is that right
now people should observe the guidelines
they should stay home they should
protect the NHS and this is ultimately
about saving lives
and you know if there are if there is
further evidence that comes forward from
Sage we will of course consider that but
up until that point the guidelines will
stay in place okay just finally and
have any update on the healthy Prime
Minister well I mean I've really pleased
that of course he is out of ICU I
understand that he is in very good
spirits he's he's walking about a bit
but what is really important I think is
that he has the rest
we all wish him the very best and we
want him to get back you know fully fit
and I think for me actually what's been
really pleasing throughout this process
of course we've all been incredibly
worried about the Prime Minister but
what's been very pleasing is that
colleagues across the political spectrum
have joined together to wish the Prime
Minister well and I think that does show
that there is a unity there's a unity of
purpose across our country and I hope
that will continue okay thank you very
much being on the program today Alec
Shana there is no secretary